[Musique]
la société est engagée dans une
véritable course contre le temps c'est
devenu pour beaucoup d'entre nous une
question existentielle et en particulier
dans l'éducation car l'enfant apprend
avec et non contre le temps plus
globalement cette course contre le temps
nous interroge tous et à quelque chose
d'un peu absurde car jusqu'à preuve du
contraire le temps gagne toujours
peux-tu me citer un homme qui accorde du
prix autant qu'ils reconnaissent la
valeur d'une journée qu'ils comprennent
qu'ils meurent chaque jour car notre
erreur c'est de voir la mort devant nous
on les sent chez elle elle est déjà
passée la partie de notre vie qui est
derrière nous appartient à la mort aussi
lucilius fais ce que tu me dit dans la
lettre saisie toit de chaque heure ainsi
tu seras moins dépendants du lendemain
puisque tu te seras emparé du jour
présent on remet la vie à plus tard et
pendant ce temps elle s'en va dans sa
première lettre à lucilius intitulé
l'emploi du temps
sénèque démontre combien la question de
la mort nous ramène à celle du sens de
notre existence et à la notion du temps
et c'est un peu ce qui m'est arrivé
longtemps vécu aux mecs et les ré
[Musique]
ancien trader j'ai travaillé pendant
plusieurs années un rythme de fou dans
ce mélange de stress de vitesse et
d'ivresse est devenue la finance moderne
[Musique]
dédié 24 heures sur 24 à mon métier je
courais chaque jour contre le temps et
d'un seul coup le ton s'est arrêté
un matin d'août le médecin de famille
m'annoncer que ma mère était atteinte
d'une maladie incurable deux ans pas
plus tout s'effondrait jamais je ne
pourrai l'accompagner si je continue
dans la finance alors je suis parti je
suis devenu instituteur
j'ai découvert un autre rythme celui de
l'enfance qui ne faut pas brusquer et
pourtant j'ai encore l'impression de
courir après le temps je regarde
l'emballement du monde et je suis pris
de vertige
les dates qui augmentent les ressources
qui s'épuisent ceux qui courent pour
suivre le rythme et ceux qui ont lâché
prise à le temps le temps il est là sans
être là toujours présent mais impalpable
un peu comme dieu en fait à la fois
origines et fin de toute chose
mais non monsieur le temps on n'a plus
du tout le temps d'y penser
précipitée dans l'urgence technologique
et médiatique et financière il est plus
du tout question de prendre du recul
encore moins de la hauteur l'impression
de ne rien ressentir n'a au fond de lui
même mais on a quand même un peu
l'impression que ça va vraiment vit donc
dans l'impression d'être un peu chez
wagram à l'exil
on va plus du côté des choses dans un
monde qui change en permanence et d'une
manière très rapide par définition ça va
tellement vite qu'on est simplement dans
la réactivité sert comme un pilote up
qui évite les les obstacles ou qui suit
le parcours sinueux mais qui servent pas
à savoir où la route va s'arrêter si la
mécanique est pas entrave qu'il n'a pas
le temps quand je suis devenu
instituteur j'ai réalisé combien pour
l'enfant le temps et clé car il est
l'instrument de son apprentissage
le langage s'apprend avec le temps c'est
par la répétition dans le temps qu'on
apprend ses tables de multiplication ou
qu'on s'améliore jusqu'à la virtuosité
petit à petit l'enfant apprend au fil de
ma pratique j'ai réalisé que ce temps
d'apprentissage varient beaucoup d'un
enfant à l'autre
issu de l'école méritocratique à la
française est d'une grande école
mon premier réflexe a été de vouloir
porter tout le monde au top niveau
j'ai voulu tout leur transmettre vite je
me suis vite aperçu que c'était
impossible voire contre-productif ce qui
explique très bien cet élève jérémy vos
travaille le bois trop quand même pas
trop comment ça lui dire d'aller plus
vite plus vite et quand on va avec
on fait comme une musique comme youtube
mais après la finale comment dire en
gagne rien parce que auquel pas beaucoup
parce que apportait à force d'aller vite
comment dire à force d'aller vite on
commença par nos moyens et on fait les
choses mal
et oui on fait les choses mal pour
l'enseignant c'est la même chose
comment un enseignant pressés et
stressés peut-il instaurer le climat de
calme et de bienveillance nécessaires à
la transmission des savoirs dans la
classe c'est une contradiction à
laquelle je fais face régulièrement sous
la pression des programmes et des
procédures à mettre en oeuvre un
syndicat d'enseignant et titrait
récemment dans son magazine 108 heures
ça déborde
si maintenant même les profs sont
débordés où va-t-on pour ce qui est des
enfants ils deux sont devenus
terriblement impatients soumis à
l'empressement des parents bringuebalé
entre le attends attends attends attends
et puis d'un seul coup dépêche-toi accro
à la technologie et aux écrans et soumis
à l'immédiateté d'internet
ils ne savent plus attendre et en plus
en plus de mal à se concentrer
il voudrait tout savoir tout de suite et
se découragent facilement pourquoi
accorder du temps à la recherche et à la
réflexion
quand google répond tout de suite à
toutes vos questions
nous sommes dans une crise de la
patience ne sommes pas dans une
accélération du temps nous sommes dans
une crise de la patience s'il ya nous
voulons que les choses aillent vite
nous voulons comprendre l'intérêt la
relativité en deux minutes et ça ça
interpelle
ils ont les scientifiques au sens où ils
se demandent comment dans ce monde là on
va pouvoir transmettre de la
connaissance non pas de l'information
comment vous pouvez transmettre de la
connaissance dans un monde qui est
saturé d'informations
alors comment faire face à cette carence
de temps si nuisible à l'enseignement
comment lutter contre ce processus
destructeur d'intelligence de cohésion
et de créativité
je vous livrais ici le fruit de mon
expérience subjective et les pistes de
réflexion sur lesquels m'ont engagé mais
dix années d'enseignement
première piste se libérer de l'idée de
perfection vous savez la sete ce vieux
dicton de grand mère qui disait le mieux
est l'ennemi du bien
le mieux est l'ennemi du bien bon il
faut chercher à bien faire mais pas trop
parce que si on sort ça trop bien faire
on va effectivement raté son truc qu'on
va le voir et on va avoir et c'est
d'ailleurs tout à fait vrai eva tom
peters en 1987 dans le chaos management
déclare non non non c'est pas ça c'est
le bien est l'ennemi du mieux donc c'est
pas du tout faisons suffisamment bien
et soyons raisonnables restons bien là
dedans c'est ça n'est jamais suffisant
faisons toujours mieux toujours mieux
toujours mieux ces dictons de nos
grands-mères et plein d'indulgence
cette indulgence qui permet
d'accompagner l'élève dans son
développement en le félicitant que c'est
déjà bien plutôt que de lui demander
encore mieux soumis à l'hyper à fait
conscient plutôt de l'hyper
compétitivité de notre société
parents et enseignants ont tendance à
demander à l'enfant toujours mieux
entretenant ainsi sa frustration mais
aussi la leur comment répondre à des
critères qui sont sans cesse plus élevés
et après ils sont un petit peu
malheureux les enfants même s'ils sont
la clastre ou alors que les mots forts
et peuvent être rejetés de là ils
peuvent être un petit peu rejetés
je crois que pour ses il faut que
l'enseignant parviennent à se libérer
lui même de cette idée de perfection
tant pour lui que pour ses élèves
on ne peut pas bouclé à 100% le
programme aujourd'hui à moins de laisser
beaucoup d'élèves sur le carreau petit à
petit on arrive à adapter ses exigences
pour que tous les élèves grâce au temps
on comprend qu'on peut permettre à tous
les élèves de progresser en réévaluant
ses exigences pour permettra
d'encourager l'enfant de le faire
progresser surtout de nourrir sa
confiance en lui
deuxième piste méditer pour retrouver
attention et cohésion cette pratique que
j'ai introduite l'année du film a
révolutionné mon métier d'enseignant
les quelques minutes de respiration
ventrale que nous accordons tous
ensemble chaque matin nourrissent la
bienveillance le calme et la tension
dans la classe elles permettent aux
enfants de réapprendre la valeur du
temps les reconnectant à leur corps et à
leur respiration ce grand métronome de
nos vies elles permettent aussi elle
permet aussi de nourrir la cohésion en
mettons toute la classe au diapason
dès le matin
troisième piste enseigner ce qu'on aime
éduquer ce n'est pas à lui remplir un
vase s'est allumé un feu disait
montaigne et comment allumer un feu si
on a pas le feu en soit le meilleur
conseil qu'il m'était donné donné quand
j'ai commencé ma carrière d'enseignant
l'a été par un ami instituteur il m'a
dit en scène ce que tu aimes car
enseigner ce qu'on aime ces thèmes est
enseignée et cet amour est
incroyablement contagieux éveiller la
curiosité des enfants à la philosophie
la mythologie
histoire les sciences c'est nourrir leur
soif de connaissances présentes et
surtout futur quatrième piste tirait
nous ramène à la question du temps à
prendre à prendre le temps tous les
enseignants le savent alterner les
rythmes laisser parfois du temps au
temps et le meilleur garant pour assurer
le bien-être et la réussite des élèves
les élèves ont besoin de temps pour
décompresser
ils ont besoin de temps pour faire des
pauses pour imaginer inventer jouer se
laver la tête pour mieux repartir
heureusement il y aller tant de
récréation mais il ya aussi tous les
temps consacrés dans la classe pour les
activités dites auto telle hic ces
activités que six scènes mais ali décrit
très bien ses activités qui nous
enrichissent sans autre but qu elle même
la musique le chant le dessin la lecture
jouer
jardiner cuisiner les enfants adorent
toutes ces activités et elle crée pour
ed pause salvatrice cinquième piste très
importante
faire du temps un allié est ce possible
je crois que la chose que préfère mes
élèves dans la semaine c'est le moment
de la citations philosophiques gide par
exemple se doit pas être si difficile
que ça de mourir puisque tout le monde y
arrive
einstein le monde ne sera pas détruit
par ceux qui font le mal mais par ceux
qui les regardent sans rien faire
existe une multitude de citations
philosophiques qui nourrissent la
réflexion des élèves et l'expérience
montre qu'ils sont avides de ces moments
de recul prendre le temps de philosopher
en classe c'est nourrir une forme de
spiritualité laïque qui fait un
contrepoint salvateur à notre société
hyper matérialiste bourré de
communication et à cette urgence qui
vident petit à petit nos vies de leur
sens en prenant le temps de philosopher
les enfants réapprennent la valeur du
temps qui est nécessaire à
l'accouchement de la pensée le temps de
les changes de la réflexion puis de
l'action je pense que l'idéal mais c'est
un idéal qui pas forcément généralisable
c'est de se donner de décider quel sens
de sa vie et de ce fait de se concentrer
sur les actions que le sens qu'on lui a
données impose
et une fois qu'on a trouvé le sens il me
semble que tout prend sens et du coup le
temps devient non plus un ennemi mais un
allié
il va permettre de construire des choses
sixième et dernière piste pour moi la
plus importante prendre le temps d'aimer
devrait conclure là dessus sur cette
question qui me touche en tant
qu'enseignant mais aussi en tant que
parents nous manquons de temps pour tout
nous manquons donc aussi de temps pour
aimer c'est quelque chose de fondamental
pour l'enfant il a besoin de cet amour
pour s'éveiller et il a besoin de cet
accompagnement aimé accompagner l'enfant
l'encourager le féliciter aussi faire
preuve d'exigence et d'indulgence tout
ça demande du temps face à des classes
de 30 élèves les enseignants font ce
qu'ils peuvent
c'est pour ça je crois qu'il faut
vraiment que les parents prennent
conscience de leur responsabilité de
prendre le temps d'aimer leurs enfants
voilà je voudrais conclure sur une
phrase d'un enfant vous appelez gabin et
qui m'a beaucoup marqué et qui illustre
selon moi tout ce que nous avons à
apprendre des enfants le temps n'existe
pas c'est l'homme qui découpent le temps
qui a inventé quelque chose pour aller
plus vite
mais c'est en fait c'est nous qui
passons de d'antan
ces notes c'est notre dur était un petit
peu le temps qui
donc le temps n'existe pas vraiment
[Musique]
voilà merci beaucoup pour votre
attention et le temps que nous avons
passé ensemble
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]